[Music]
[Applause]
it's safe to say John B brought it on
home
I have a really hot date tonight making
their official red carpet debut as a
couple Kelsey ballerini and Chase Stokes
take on the CMT Music Awards this is
kind of our first like outing so I'm
like come on into my world and then
bring me to Charleston and I'll be in
yours it'll be fun that's for Carrie
Underwood it was a mom's night out my
husband's got the kiddos well let's get
this party started what a way to start
Kelsey who served as the knights co-host
alongside Kane Brown
also gave us an amazing performance that
featured very special guests there is a
surprise tonight
yep joining Kelsey on stage were four
fabulous Queens from RuPaul's Drag Race
[Music]
a powerful performance comes after
certain states have been pushing for
anti-drag bills it is bright and it is
celebratory and is happy and it is
important and of course Chase was
singing along to Kelsey in the audience
it was quite the night for Kelsey's
co-host Kane she's beautiful she can
sing she got everything full package
full package that's why you married her
hello sweet that's sweet and the winner
Kane Brown and Caitlyn Brown thank God
taking home video of the year the happy
couple also performed the love song
and from one hottie to another
Megan the stallion presents Shania Twain
with the equal play award Man I Feel
Like a Woman let's ensure that all our
fellow artists get equal play regardless
gender age or race
[Music]